These scenes would have been unthinkable days ago.
Sri Lanka's seat of presidential power now a sightseeing destination.
Security nowhere to be seen...
...as thousands push their way in to a palace taken over by protesters.
The man who once lived here, President Gotabaya Rajapaksa,...
...has now fled and is expected to step down this week.
As they look around the lavish rooms,...
...Sri Lankans continue to contend with a deepening economic crisis.
After months of frustration, this feels like a release,...
...crowds surging through the doors to get inside this presidential palace...
...and get a peek of what life is like in Sri Lanka's political class.
A palace overrun.
A country in crisis.
Protesters say they won't leave until the president officially quits.
But even once he does, who can save this nation in need?
For Sri Lanka, the challenges keep on coming.